let's get started uh so for the last
Talk of the student session oh God Ian
Mertz
uh so I guess just take it away Bud all
right uh
So yeah thank you to everyone uh for
coming and thank you to the organizers
for allowing me to speak at this venue
um
so I am going to talk about a line of
work that I worked on throughout my PhD
and continue to work on that I really
like and I'm going to give kind of a
student's eye view of it aka the order
in which it happened and not the order
in which uh really makes sense
um so it's only in retrospect of course
with Tony that we can piece it together
and make something cohesive
um and let me just start at the
beginning which is me coming to Toronto
so I did my it was the you know the
visit times and I visited UCLA for a few
days
um and then I was super bummed to fly
back from UCLA to the east coast
Princeton because it was a drop of
whatever 10 degrees and the weather got
visibly murkier and then when I went to
Toronto the same thing happened with
respect to the east coast I showed up
and it was pouring rain uh it was
miserably cold and my first thought off
the plane was well at least they're
giving me a free visit
um and it took eight hours to convince
me to come to University of Toronto from
that and it basically happened because
of three conversations uh the first was
just talking to Steve Cook realizing he
was research active uh that was not the
conversation it was about uh like boats
and the Opera and other stuff that he
likes
uh it was going to the bar with Robert
Robert my co-organizer uh who was uh
very social uh extremely so and most of
all of course it was talking to Tony uh
who is kind of the best of all of these
worlds uh who is obviously extremely
social and fun and who has a great knack
for research and makes those
conversations so exciting so I felt like
Toronto after that I really felt like
Toronto was the right place to be uh and
I'm in retrospect of course it was the
right place to be so
when I got there I was co-advised by
Steve and Tony and there's a rite of
passage for everyone who uh works with
Steve uh which is you have to work on
the tree evaluation problems
so yes uh the tree evaluation problem uh
this is uh Steve's uh pet problem and
that he's been really working seriously
on since I think 2009 or so uh it looks
as the following uh you have a full uh
binary tree given to you as input where
at each of the leaves you have an
element
um say
or X2 X3 X4 and TP is characterized by
an alphabet size K so each of these
things is an element
in the alphabet size K and then in the
internal nodes uh you're actually given
an entire function uh which takes in two
inputs over K and spits out an output
over K uh and of course
the way you evaluate this thing is uh
from the bottom up those aren't matched
there we go uh so
the tree has height H which is the other
parameter for GP and you evaluate this
in an actual way you start with your
leaves you feed them into the function
labeling the node right above them you
take the output you go up and up and up
and uh that's what you get
and
Steve uh and Tony and Jeff Edmonds and a
couple of other people uh were working
on showing that this thing uh is uh
so the conjecture was that TP
is in
polytime but not in log space
so showing it's in polytime is easy you
kind of do the algorithm I just outlined
but uh the whole goal was to show that
it's not in log space and Steve had an
even more ambitious conjecture which is
that he said
um
but TP requires space
uh well let's just say it this way
it requires space like H Times log K
which if you want to work out the
parameters this is more than log space
but the intuition is simple
let's say I want to compute the top note
of this tree if I want to do that I'm
going to have to compute both of the
children so let's say I just give you
one of them for free you do all your
work on this left side and you get an
answer now you have to compute the right
node in order to get this and what do
you have well you have a tep instance of
height one less and you're remembering
some element for here so now let's do
the same thing you compute the left over
here now you can get the right and you
work your way down and the idea is you
have to remember like H minus 1
different elements Each of which
requires log K bets and that was uh the
conjecture and it was proved for many
natural restrictions of course I'm
talking about space here but the whole
discussion was with respect to branching
programs so uh where you can impose nice
uh conditions on them and
um
well uh it was proven for many special
cases uh and what ended up coming out of
it was there was this one problem that
uh Jeff raised really nicely uh which
was called uh the ZF problem this is my
first time encountering the letter the
pronunciation Zed as well I'm from the
US
so the ZF problem is kind of uh exactly
as uh it's like exactly what I just
outlined the idea is you're given an
input X and some long string Z and you
want to you have a turing machine where
the work tape already has Zed written on
it
and you want to compute F on X at the
end output uh the answer to F with Z
still written down there and the
conjecture is
um
the space of this
is equal to like the space required to
compute f
plus the size of your string Z
and the reason why uh we needed to study
this problem is because in the argument
I just outlined well you're remembering
all these uh values going down the tree
but there's nothing that says you have
to uh you know save that space and not
use it for anything else it's just it
should be obvious that you can't do
anything with this because it's
completely irrelevant uh and so I of
course bashed my head against the wall
for most of my masters and it was hard
uh in fact Jeff Evans at one point uh
made a little quick which is that if I
can make uh pretty much any progress if
I could solve this I could immediately
have my PhD uh now Jeff was not my
advisor and is not at University of
Toronto so uh he is in no position to
say this
um
and when I realized this fact I moved on
to a different problem
but
uh to give a sneak preview of what's to
come this uh this prefigured the kind of
work uh even though I pivoted from here
on out uh this prefigured a really
interesting line of work uh called
composition theorems which is
essentially what I want to talk about
today
so there's a lot of different ways to
think about composition theorems here's
one that I like let's say you have a uh
a task that you think is hard so you
know we've got we try and come up with
hard functions all the time so we go
into our uh a big bag of hard functions
and we we come up with uh this one
uh and it's a natural hard problem in
the sense that you know it's phrased in
some nice task but one of the main
reasons we think it's hard is because if
you actually look inside F there's like
a first step you have to do and then a
second step and then a third step and
all the way down
big
um and this is one reason I that we
think it's hard with respect to you know
your favorite uh measure of complexity
but the challenge that you're facing is
that well an algorithm may not do one
two three all the way down you know
that's the obvious way but it may
actually uh you know do some other stuff
foreign
that makes together makes you know a
whole chunk of this become easy or you
know solves it at one time and this is
what we don't want uh when we're
designing our hard functions we want to
make it so that algorithms really do
have to go through this long process so
one intuition is why not just uh build F
in exactly this way why don't I just
come up with steps one two three up to
big and I will make them as completely
uncorrelated and distinct as possible
such that there should be nothing that
you can do to uh save time at doing uh
by doing multiple of them at once
because they're just totally unrelated
and this is sort of the intuition behind
this tep thing where all these nodes I'm
going to give a function that uh ensures
that you can't like uh rely on the
correlations between the functions
inside the tree and some such things so
then your task uh essentially boils down
to the following let's say you've got a
complexity measure of Interest s
and you have a way of combining tasks so
here I wrote it that you have to do them
in order over there you could think of
maybe uh doing them in parallel anyway
you have this list of tasks and you have
a way of combining them uh this is
composition symbol Circle and what you
want to show is that for pretty much all
functions f and g
um pretty much all on hiding some stuff
under the rug uh and your complexity
measure s that you care about this thing
is roughly the complexity of f plus the
complexity of G
and if you get this then this gives you
a recipe for cooking up hard functions F
uh which is you just you know we don't
know super hard functions f and g but we
know ones that say uh you know take
exactly logarithmic space and we combine
them over and over and over again and
eventually we end up with something
bigger uh that requires larger
complexity
so all right perfect uh let's see this
uh in practice in a field that is not
space and is in fact what I started
working on uh after I left this behind
um and it's basically just tep with a
change of parameters so I think this was
originally called the iterated
multiplexer problem and it's uh
now it's parameterized by like height
and Fannin and it's the exact same
picture uh but instead of having an
alphabet size I have a different famine
all right nothing going on there so I
still have an entire function labeling
it at the tree but now let's say uh
everything is just binary zero one
inputs and now instead of taking two
inputs uh and spitting out one it takes
in uh D inputs
and spits out one and again you know I
do this all the way down I'm not going
to draw this
smell yeah yeah yeah so these are
actually like uh you know you can think
of them as end D dimensional but yeah
yes Newton constantly coded using a
larger alphabet in the sense that
um
it's I guess this version you can sort
of cover this version by doing the
individual bits of it the other way
around it's not clear I mean these are
very closely related problems that just
went by different names uh which of
course was enough to throw me off as a
graduate student because when Tony
showed me this problem I went oh thank
God I can start working on tep
um
yeah
it's a very golden graduate student so
uh this uh it was proposed back in the
90s so a while before this tep problem
came up uh and the goal here was to
separate
um
came from a different class
which is nc1
which is uh the set of all uh Boolean
formulas and this is equivalent to the
set of all uh Boolean formulas of
logarithmic depth and so we're here we
were thinking of getting around
logarithmic Space by a composition
argument here we're doing the same thing
with Def and it relies on a conjecture
that looks very much like this uh is
that F problem and this was uh this is
well known and it's called the KRW
conjecture
which says that uh and I'm going to
phrase it in well they all phrase it as
a Boolean formulas it's that the formula
complexity or the leaf complexity
however you want to write it of f
composed with G and composition is in
exactly this sense that I write here
where you uh take uh F and then you feed
in a bunch of copies of other functions
let's say even just the same function G
uh this complexity is roughly the
complexity of f plus the complexity of G
uh
uh plus right it's log depth we're
talking about this isn't lifting
oh oh sorry you're right I
thought I was doing something wrong
there we go
yes good good good
conjecture to be
it's almost the same if you have Ellen
products oh sure
but uh that would be historically
inaccurate
um
now this is uh you know for the
complexity people everyone sees formula
depth and immediately goes okay
communication complexity uh and we're
not going to go into communication with
Lexi today but uh suffice it to say that
one reason we can talk about this is
that um it is related to this field
communication complexity where we do
think quite a bit about uh composition
already so for example everyone's
favorite hard function set disjointness
is uh you know a composed problem it's a
function that looks like an or
um of a bunch of ands on two bits
and this function is known to be hard
so you know very basic function but the
hardness comes in immediately and there
are other uh examples of functions which
are um
composed functions
and
the other big area that came up in the
last 20 years or so uh that has to do
with composition in this realm is that
of lifting theorems uh which is what I
actually worked on so
can anyone see back here no
lifting theorems have a similar sort of
structure and again I don't want to go
into it but the idea is if we can't
proof this for all f and g let's prove
it in a setting where we can do it so
it's F composed with a specific uh fixed
function G which we picked to be kind of
uh maximally hard and instead of
studying the connections between depth
and depth it's depth and some weaker
um measure of complexity and there's all
these reasons why it's slightly
different from KRW but the important
thing is that in studying this this is
uh just to write it here
um
foreign
if you recognize this thing you
recognize it if you don't then that's
fine but um
well the goals here are slightly
different uh when we study this sort of
question which has a huge line of Works
behind it we are studying uh in part
techniques that may one day converge in
KRW and so what Tony and I worked on uh
throughout the last couple years of my
PhD uh
tell me
uh is understanding the uh what is
essentially going on in a statement like
this and trying to get to the depths of
like what mathematical objects are
involved here and in the future uh in
fact this I'll just say
combinatorics and in particular the
sunflower Lemma which has seen a lot of
recent uh developments in the past
couple years and a lot of recent
applications and uh these two things are
now known to be very intimately
connected and what I hope to do in the
future uh
is to connect these sorts of arguments
to KRW as well and so I really wanted to
understand uh what was going on because
I want to eventually make progress on
hard problems like these
uh and then I'll just say that there was
a twist
uh
so I ended up back here actually uh
James Cook came to a seminar uh or a
workshop much like this one about his
dad's work with an amazing idea about
why this should just uh not be true and
so we spent some time on it and we found
out in fact that this is uh not true
um
yeah
we found out that tep is actually uh in
uh slower space than Steve conjectured
um it was H over log h
Times log K not a not the biggest uh
quantitative Improvement but really had
to use all kinds of techniques and in
particular uh showed that this is not
true so this shows that this is a
finicky question this composition one
somehow we've been working for uh
decades now and showing that when it
comes to formulas and such and depth uh
composition works like a dream and then
out of nowhere we find out that if you
move from nc1 up to L it doesn't work
the way that we wanted to anymore so
this whole question of what you can and
can't do with composition I I think is
eternally fascinating and Tony of course
walked me through this my whole way uh
and I'll end with uh saying exactly how
she uh
help me at the end
this is all a nice retrospective on how
these things work together
again I was not uh so attuned to these
questions and at the time I didn't
realize that multiplexer and tep were
really talking about the same things I
focused in on lifting and so when it
came time to write a thesis and the
research statement
um here's my first draft of my research
statement I said quote I am particularly
drawn to problems where the mathematical
objects in question are very basic and
yet with a bit of cleverness they can
yield results which are surprising but
also accessible and to translate that I
can't do hard math so I only do easy
math
um Tony of course saved my career by
vetoing this
and in retrospect I can see why I
thought these things might be just
totally unrelated because to me Tony
works on literally everything and if
Tony worked on tep and uh lifting
theorems then Tony worked on tep and
lifting theorems but I've grown to
appreciate uh since wrapping up my PhD
but Tony
yes works very very broadly but also has
a really Keen sense of how these things
are connected and where the hardness
really comes from and has this beautiful
view of all these different objects uh
together and well knows how to push
graduate students to see the same thing
in their own time so uh it was a
fantastic PhD and I hope to continue
making progress in this on the future so
happy Birthday Tony
[Applause]
things
Ian
um any questions
is there a modified Zeta conjecture
if Zed is very small I guess but again
uh you can't get it small enough that
you don't get some improvements
that's a good question uh I don't this
seems fairly unnatural but we've had
more unnatural things be the right
answer before uh I I could still believe
that this is not in log space but uh it
doesn't look like we've hit the wall for
catalytic techniques or for for the
techniques involved in this just yet
um
studying this question purely on its own
terms I think is pretty cool and seeing
how far you can push up
so can I say more about some intuition
about like why the conjecture is false
this one uh yeah or like what the
counter examples are like there's an uh
there's a number of different subtle
ways in which it could fail in this case
[Music]
um
it really
there's a great way to explain it uh
well yeah you can reuse the space
certainly
um I mean I guess that's the long and
short of it right like uh
like this is false because uh because it
fails on its own terms we said that Zed
should somehow come along for the ride
and never come into play here that
somehow you can disconnect uh Computing
F from Computing everything else that
you already did before and this just
turns out uh to not uh it just turns out
that you can always use this uh in some
way that while it's completely
uncorrelated with f you look at F in a
different light you sort of tilt your
head and turn it into something where uh
any extra space can be used uh in a way
that can be returned but there's no
great I don't have a great answer for
why it should fail here and succeed over
there
um oh is this for someone specific app
no this is uh this holds for every F
uh
this tree evaluation problem uh this
result regardless of which functions you
plug into the intermediate nodes uh you
can get this oh thanks yeah
so here did you ever collect the hundred
dollars associated with that conjunction
oh yeah right so Steve Cook uh
um there's James fifty dollars and he
owes me fifty dollars
um he also has probably paid for more
things than I would really like to
recall so I could call it even or just
uh air dish style take the check and
frame it on my wall uh I'd be happy with
any of this but no and Steve if you're
watching this call me
Russell
[Music]
um could there be some connection
between this and the ZF problem and
reversible computation so it seems for
sure I mean everything we do is
everything we do to disprove this is
reversible uh I think the more maybe
more interesting question is can you
come up with ways to falsify the ZF
conjecture that don't use reversible
computation we don't know uh we don't
know of any techniques that don't and if
all we can do here is like stuff that
works into the Zed and then reverses it
later
um in some predictable way then there's
a lot of then this won't go so far like
this can only you know space reusing
space will only be so interesting uh I
but for sure reversible computation is a
much bigger field uh than just this
problem and I don't think we've kind of
we've explored all those connections yet
yes uh I have a similar question uh but
instead of a reversible uh I would like
to ask you about possible connection to
catalytic computations right so this is
um all right so I actually worked on tep
twice before I came to Toronto I just
didn't take it very seriously uh as an
undergraduate uh Michal Koski uh visited
Rutgers with this cool new paper called
catalytic Computing uh and as you've all
said the whatever the first paper you
read is you imprint onto it and you
can't think about anything else for the
rest of your life so this uh I I I'm
glad that this happens because otherwise
I was never going to exercise this demon
from my mind but um yes
catalytic Computing is intimately
involved in this and that's why I said I
want to know if there's more than
reversible because right now catalytic
all we can do is some amount of
reversible uh stuff with space and while
it's all well and good uh that means
we'll never get beyon say Paul in real
time uh with catalytic log space if this
is for people who know what this is but
uh for people who don't know what it is
could you define it all right so imagine
you have a hard drive and it's
sorry this is uh we all say this in our
papers so imagine you've got uh two work
tapes one which is very small say log
space and one which is enormous say all
the size uh but it's completely filled
in sort of in this exact ZF sense if I
give you that work tape you know can you
do anything more than log space is the
question and the answer is yes you can
get like non-deterministic log space and
more
do we know if it's in p no we don't um
but if everything is all you do is
reversible then yes we'll do no better
and the constraint is that you have to
have and you have to reset it at the end
yeah like you can't just forget your
answers up here
all right I think we're running low on
time
so
uh
uh if you have any other questions for
the speaker please take it offline
yeah thank you so much
[Applause]